c'est l'un des plus grands mythes de
l'histoire
certains ont cherché sa trace en vain
d'autres l'ont porté à l'écran en film
est en jeu vidéo mais l'atlantide at
elle réellement existé ailleurs que dans
notre imagination et si oui où se
trouve-t-elle michael donnellan fait
partie de ceux qui pensent pouvoir
répondre à cette question pour cet
américain féru d'archéologie la clé de
l'énigme se trouve dans ce livre en
l'espace d'un jour et d'une nuit funeste
l'île de l'atlantide juste engloutis
dans les profondeurs de l'âme et la
légende vient de ce texte du philosophe
grec platon et michael est convaincu
d'avoir trouvé entre ces lignes
l'emplacement de la cité perdue quelque
part en andalousie
gers il est écrit qu'il faut passer les
colonnes d'hercule et l'on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit de gibraltar
donc on est dans la bonne c'est tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur l'atlantide hélas
dans mes mains
pour nous prouver que son intuition est
la bonne michael nous emmène à marée
basse sur une plage voisine
c'est là nous dit il qu'il a fait une
découverte surprenante
il ya deux ans une violente tempête a
déplacé d'énormes quantités lisa et a
révélé les restes d'une ancienne
sa technique pour sonder les profondeurs
prendre de la hauteur
si vous regardez autour de vous vous
aurez l'impression de ne voir que des
pierres ce n'est qu'avec le drone une
fois en l'air que l'on peut vraiment
voir ce qu'il y a
toutes ces images il les analyse dans
son studio pour lui il n'ya pas de doute
encore moins après avoir scanné les
fonds marins
ça ne peut pas être naturel on voit des
blocs rectangulaires qui dessine des
rues des avions
michael mais pas le seul chercheur
d'atlantique dans la région aujourd'hui
il accompagne manuel dans le parc de
dounia n'a une réserve naturelle qui
autrefois avait un visage bien différent
là par exemple on a la preuve que doute
cette zone était recouverte par la mer
il y à des milliers d'années j'ai
regardé ses côtés il y avait une mer
intérieure ici qu'ils allaient jusqu'à
saint lambert intérieur il n'en fallait
pas plus pour que les deux acolytes
imagine ici la cité de l'atlantide tels
que platon l'a décrite une seule couleur
quand la ville était formé de cercles
concentriques presque parfait séparés
par des canaris
une forme qui rappelle étrangement celle
de ses ruines plus au nord dans la
région de castilla la mancha
certains ont une théorie les concernant
je pense que les athlètes qui ont
survécu un cataclysme se sont réfugiées
ici à l'intérieur des nous rencontrons
sur place un archéologue spécialisé dans
les civilisations antiques et nesta
aussi on a dû enterrer des morts pendant
presque mille ans mais la nuit pour lui
ces vestiges ne sont ni grec ni romain
il ne ressemble à rien de connu
toutes les pierres ont une forme très
régulière et en même temps aaron il n'y
a pas de bloc droit c'est une
architecture très ancienne et qui
s'inscrit dans une tradition
particulière
de quoi inspirer et valentina un
entrepreneur qui croit dur comme fer que
les atlantes et est ibérique chaque
année ils financent des fouilles comme
celle ci à hauteur de 35 mille euros
l'âme est l'antidote un sujet
passionnant qui fait rêver comme les
dinosaures ou l'egypte tente si l'on
peut prouver son existence ce serait un
tremblement
imaginer le nombre de touristes que cela
pourrait
pour l'heure aucune de ces théories n'a
été validé scientifiquement laissant
planer
sur l'existence de la cité légendaire
peut-être foulerez vous un vestige
atlante lors de vos vacances dans le sud
de l'espagne pour peu que vous ayez
décidé d'y croire
[Musique]